[Music]
[Applause]
uh
hello children and adults around the
world merry christmas
from us and surf shark sir
shock vpn provider
always say what's funny
always safe keeping you
private you can use it as a browser
extension
or just an app it's good on both
i'm going to read the ad
sleep in heavenly
the first two things you think about
when you think of christmas is surfing
and sharks it's a vpn app and browser
extension which basically allows you to
put yourself anywhere in the world so
whether you be here
in britain away from the rest of the
world or away in the rest of the world
so you'll go hey
let's go to america because for instance
i want to access some content which is
only available within the united states
of america you'll put sir shock on and
then from there
you can watch your netflix you can watch
your other platforms you can watch all
sorts of things that maybe you can't
watch while you're in the uk
or somewhere else in the world that's
serve shark it also allows you to
encrypt your data and remain
anonymous online basically makes you
look like this
that was a reenactment of jesus's birth
of course the best gift you can give
this christmas
is surf sharp to all your family so on
christmas day a day like this
make sure your family walk down and see
surf shark under their tree
figuratively speaking as it's a app and
browser extension now in this following
podcast jackmate says this
i wouldn't spit in his mouth alex says
this daddy turns up and he's a frog
and stephen looks like this they all
want you to download surf shark
so head over to the link in the
description enter promo code geordie
and get the amazing surf shark deal
there's 84
off and four extra months free thank you
very much
and now it's time for a christmas story
it was the night before christmas
and in the locked in house not a jack
mate could be heard for reasons that we
can't disclose
it was a youtube big brother locked in
something happened in there so i had to
leave i i i left pretty pretty asap
so how many days were you in i was in
there for an hour stephen
welcome back to the treasure audi
podcast christmas special merry
christmas
we are covered because this is our job
and there is a thing that the government
did release saying that video shoot days
are still alive
everybody buy a camera hang out with
your mates
can say anything and no one can cancel
them i've realized that because people
switch off when he talks
yeah that's so true why have you turned
into a breakfast radio dj
i had some girl ask me once to say
something dirty so i went
spit in my mouth and she went that's
[__] disgusting
the more i watch the crowd the more i
realize just what a [__] load of [__]
the royal family
it's just one big pistol and they're
just sitting cream off the top get all
the money no one questions them
on top so she wanted a bit of sexy talk
yeah and i really struggled
my voice isn't sexy i used to do my own
handsome it's terrible
your form is woeful but your tits are
fantastic
the two on top are doing very well and
over the christmas period
she gave me a used butt plug really yeah
wow
i've got a book plug on mr potato head
my mate pulled it off the engineers came
around the other day yeah
the electricians the [__] going i'm
going mate i've lost them stop looking
at them
i did that first simon video i did that
to make tobe just
laugh why are you watching us here see
you big start one two three
christmas special merry christmas
[Applause]
awkward what is this is this just a me
and you think stephen do you think
will just doesn't i am part of that as
well
i got that vibe on the tour halfway
through he said you could [__] off
stephen it's me or you stay there
for those who are wondering now will is
under the weather
so you know regulations and all that
will be very true
stay safe will um is it lightweight
anywhere earnings
yeah like me hardcore no see i've got
all the symptoms and i braved it anyway
covered we got one of these i didn't
know that the e lads
um we got the relevant one yeah yeah
yeah got the relevant we didn't was in
the news this one so that's the
the most important one yeah it's been a
big year for you actually hasn't it yeah
yeah i took four months off lawrence
yeah i know
yeah who didn't that's standard for me
right yeah really
that's called the writing week yeah
let's have an argument who got the most
oppressed this year yeah
oh that's a great question jack was
weirdly productive this year sort of
annoying that he's saying
he threw up good this year yeah when i
had no competition because everyone was
stuck
was like i'll do something now did we
not see steven tries podcast by ro pens
the other day
we didn't no one did no pence my lowest
point biggest we've been at the topic
we were joking i'd say my lowest
no i was that useless so i said
something but it bounced
yeah so we need to get you on the
contract yeah anyone who cares about
their other creators tends to cut them
in on the why have you gone for a toffee
finger alex that's a rogue choice
yeah i don't know says something about
your personality
[Music]
and you can't just say because of his
personality because that won't wash with
me or his brother
child yeah that's good
that's good yes that doesn't play his
name's i though
yeah what is his name
oh yeah crazy why'd you call yourself
i'm alex
um because i am alex really lauren alex
was fine
could have just stuck with that no no
because he couldn't get the username in
who's the who's the original alex then
probably the great alex the great yeah
yeah that's what they used to claim
yeah i'm gonna need a straw for this my
beard's going to [__] already forgot
these things
buddy yes you know the thing i love
about that is two people behind the
camera went [__]
this is going to be a [__] show no it's
not no stay tuned
historically this is the one that gets
edited out the most by a male 1
i say bad things but will you used to
sit there and go we can't say that
kind of good that was not yet because
normally we have to edit out half an
hour of stuff that he's like i'll get
two but we will all get cancelled well
that's fine
you can't cancel me after i did
madeleine mccandle if you allow that to
slide
everything else is golden i've gotta say
shout out to gymshark as well sponsoring
the podcast
for them massive here sort of bigger
than me as well
and surf shark shots all the vpns
any of the sharks hammerhead yeah
the uh hammer my head the truth is
actually the cheap stuff is better than
the yeah the cheap stuff sweeter is what
it worked out
yeah i find that was possible once went
to a wedding where the guy didn't like
champagne so we
had everyone have ribena no i'm not even
kidding was it was it a religious
wedding no no no
no you know i tried red wine for the
first time yesterday what
sorry like i've just sat on this table
like what what's that reaction about
sorry how old are you he's bringing [__]
up early
for a start i took that as an insult
that's normally after the full point
it takes an hour yeah you think the
table is brown for a reason
at this point in your life you got your
spotify deal still
tried red wine no is that what you're
supposed to do
mate i tried it very young genuinely i
love red wine it's like
me and lars love a bottle don't we glug
it so i was [__]
i never glitched i didn't i did a taste
test so i got robbie knox bought an
expensive bottle of medium
i knew it would be a rugby knocks that
and um i [__] hated it
you didn't like all of it it's
disgusting how many types of red wine
did you try so they were all the same
type uh all from argentina all the same
good grapes
great apparently that's what he said i
don't know what that means and um
well when i say like an expensive bottle
i'm not talking about like your kind of
level you know i mean i'm like hundred
pound bottle that's expensive that's
pretty expensive
yeah i don't know and i tried it and the
worst one was the expensive one
it's an acquired taste yeah soft and
fruity this is it
it's not a soft and fruity
why sorry you've gone all those years
without having drunk
you've drunk white wine though uh yeah
probably
i'm with jack on this though
that was a i've been in some states or
probably yeah
but you know what i like how i like wine
i like it i like this glass
and some oh yeah some olives some some
nice cheese
mediterranean oh that sounds good a bit
of bread on the amalfi coast
yeah brian doesn't go for the amalfi
coast he just sort of goes to with me
italian food i love it
yeah what a mouthy coast the amalfi
coast it's just below naples
oh i thought it was the type of wine oh
no no one expected this on this podcast
it doesn't feel like christmas
it really doesn't it's not christmas
it's because well we don't stop grafting
no one's ever said that i'm pretty sure
it's the opposite yeah
why am i the only one that's turned up
in a christmas jumper oh come on
christmas i'm trying no it's not well
i've made an attempt
you dress better when you come to
football that's
jack i'm gonna let you take the floor of
this one because you've got some great
stories about me when he tells him
people have to believe in january he
came down
and we did a thing in norwich and then
we went and played five aside
and uh he scored a hat trick and he
scored an overhead kick on a fiver side
picture she is pissed me off does that
quite a lot
yeah overhead height rule load yeah it
got to
so you're not you're not too you're not
too bad which is weird because you don't
look like you'd be good
yeah i've got i've got a bone to pick
you guys i remember when you go
on shoreditch got brought up on one of
the true geordie videos yeah i remember
you said the level wouldn't be that high
it isn't it is very high have you seen
elliott elliot how can he plays and he
is a beast
i've haven't i've been gone the level's
increased lately
and you might not be hacking it very
well
i don't know that's just what i'm
hearing what's great about that i'd say
that second hand didn't know that it's
not my fault because i've never been
there
so why did you not play who else said
why do i
um sort of ryan you are good a bit of a
profession
yeah boy mate no professionals
no i'll be honest i'm too fat uh
some people have really let themselves
go during lockdown just just go by the
bmi
yeah yeah yeah let's just think we're
all waiting lawrence
you're the only one who's not being
canceled alex is very skinny
yeah yes it's not me can say anything
and no one can cancel him i've realized
that
he's bulletproof because people switch
off when he talks
why have you turned into a breakfast
radio dj
what does it mean what i love is every
time i watch one of your clips
you you have music as a bed under some
of it and it really makes me think of
i don't do the editing breakfast radio
djs i'm i'm feeling
there's some tension here no oh is it is
it without
no is it chuck moore's editor is in the
room editor and driver
um
[Music]
she will not i can tell you now she will
not come up well you know she's in the
room we need somebody to replace well
we did try and invite mir actually even
though will wasn't here well yeah she is
the personality of that relationship
yeah
yeah i'm the looks and the balls so yeah
um yeah wow what does she need him for
anymore that is the real quiz
hmm the real quiz oh god genuinely
seriously though jack why do you have a
bed all the way through the clips
what on what like on the clips on
youtube i don't i don't have a bed on
the clips
i've never noticed it i have an intro
there's no bathroom the intro just rings
through your head
and sometimes it goes sort of yeah and
that's when my friend topped himself
did it and i'm like oh [__] hell this
is [__] this is getting dark it's not
happy or an hour
no that's very true actually yeah
yeah very memorable yeah alliteration at
its finest
we had uh one of our most few clips was
alex talking about his cancer
yeah what is that belle delphine i'm
finally taking it up the ass dude
yeah she's uh she's an interesting
character she's very switched up i doubt
it
she's quite skinny she's uh she's she's
belle del theme brian
she's um she follows me on twitter i
didn't realize that
she gave me a used butt plug really yeah
wow used oh you've got it here right now
yeah i never take it out
was it how did you what is that what was
it key ring or where did you put that
yeah it on the shelf you put up your
nails
you know what i mean i mean a lot of
people asked that question
where would you put that well um
but she does seem to be playing blind
i just realized i mean we're gonna give
her some free promo but what the [__]
she's actually releasing her sex tape
like on september yesterday which isn't
the day
so now we're going to outdo her whoa oh
come on laurence
speech i mean which one would you rather
watch
what out of what sorry with the queen's
speech i'm getting into the queen lately
though because i watched about the crowd
and i was like queen he was kind of good
luck well this is the this is the
youngest yeah yeah she's all right this
is the one before olivia coleman
[Applause]
is that true she the queen never cried
victorious there's a problem with her
for sure
the more i watch the crowd the more i
realize just what a [__] load of [__]
the royal family
is just one big piss-up yeah they never
do anything no they're like we're not
getting involved the political
politicians can sort this out yeah and
they're just sitting cream off the top
get all the money no one questions them
have you seen it on
that's not illegal i think i'm pretty
sure andrew's had sex
i'm just going to put it out there i
don't think this will cancel me andrew
prince andrew has come on at least one
pair of tits in his life all right well
they haven't developed but he has wow
wow
that could be liable i don't know if
that's libelous well
if he comes out and says i've never done
that i've never done that yeah
my favorite thing the best thing i know
the reason i know i can say that is
because i know he's got bigger fish to
fry
yeah yeah he's got other things to deny
before he denies that
they do like the odd trip to africa and
they like
yeah most of the scenes of the queen
she's shooting tears yeah is that really
the whole show i mean
my favorite character and it's prince
philip he's just such an [__]
yeah but a lot of people fancied the
prince philip when he's been played by
uh
smith yeah such a bastard so he's always
the same she's she's become a bit of a
royalist in the past week going oh i
love
the queen and she's like oh prince
philip's an [__]
that's not royalist is it though she
fancy prince philip right
it's uh it's one of the she worked out
that the queen's son is prince andrew
and they've kept that quiet to be fair
yeah they actually have you know it's
like you'd think oh he's maybe a cousin
of someone no
do you think he still is or maybe he is
maybe that's the reason he's in this
position he's
unfavorable but they make a point of
like he's a bit of a sexual deviant
early on and they're like they hint that
you get away with murder and stuff yeah
i mean not not literally
not literally that wasn't murdered on
the other hand
well whatever whatever you want to think
about diana i only found out this year
that diana wasn't the queen's daughter
and that's not a lie are you serious
that's not it was that when you were
drinking the wine
i genuinely are you [__] serious 100
percent i don't
believe this they say a lot of things
about norwich but [__] me i know it's
murder shelter it's one thing yeah yeah
yeah i feel silly i'll admit but that is
that yeah
that's the truth i looked into it this
year dianna's death and then
oh my god so don't judge me it's so
dodgy obviously there's all these
conspiracies about how she died and
whether or not the queen may or may not
have had a part to play in it
so up until 27 years of age i thought
the queen was an evil [__] killing
their own daughter
right turns out his daughter-in-law is a
stranger
yeah have you ever seen mother-in-law or
bitching or whatever it is
when you do an interview and basically
out
the prince i was having an affair
there were three of us in this
relationship yeah and he was
basically [__] camilla the entire
time before during after
you know he probably she's a downgraded
man that's the thing which means camilla
is a
she's a stinker i'm just putting that
out there well maybe that's why
maybe that's why he likes it one up
there charles took a fat l on that
what what's weird is camilla i'm getting
really into this now camilla [__]
meets up with diana
early doors and she's like oh yeah do
you not know he likes this and he likes
that and she's like [__] with diana's
head
what kind of stuff does she see she say
like well she's like oh do you know his
favorite food is you know what he likes
this oh he calls me this this is my
nickname
she's blatantly like getting in diana's
head and diana
she's like bulimic and stuff it's very
simple harry and megan for two jobs 2021
that'd be amazing
and then obviously he's in a
relationship with dodie fayad who's like
muhammad al-fayed so i was gonna say
he's not my favorite fired and
she comes out swinging putting the
putting the pressure on the royal family
boom apparently she said to a butler
if i die in a car accident yeah he left
the left charles sadly butler was a
complete wanker so nobody
believes it's yeah
just ironically it's not renaissance is
there a guy that went like a big brother
and [__] himself over the rats
did he shut him down no i was looking to
get me out of here right oh yeah what
the other one yeah
well there are rats i'm pretty sure
they're rats in balmoral
there was a there was a youtube big
brother locked in
look went in did you go in no thank god
now it shows how many episodes you
watched
i didn't watch anybody the only clips i
saw were jack and
uh yeah yeah she was on there
sure um and some other clips of just
everyone everyone was just
really boring honestly i'm not i know
it's done now so we can say whatever we
want like
it's done they are done out here it was
one of the most boring series of
anything
everybody goes into the diary room they
go oh i never knew
he could read all right he's so smart
like somebody give him some credit yeah
just because jms started a few
businesses people think he's the brains
of britain though
right it's like credible you're in there
with facebook pranksters if you start
if you start a business you are alex he
is right okay
yeah you're fired yeah call back
we all make mistakes so don't we we all
make mistakes so i don't even know what
kind of alluded to did something happen
between you and jeremiah
he voted him out no so something
happened in there so i had to leave i
i i left pretty pretty asap so how many
days were you in
i was in there for an hour stephen
i would have done to be fair closer yeah
yeah
you know what i mean yeah i made it very
clear i was going in there for the money
yeah
and and i left did you get all the money
100 of the money yeah because i didn't
know
how did you leave after an hour what
happened uh something something some
things went on in there some things went
on in there because it was all on the in
the video
no no no after a few more of them yeah
okay it's fine just who did you sleep
um because this is a thing that people
don't know right he's a good guy so i'm
not going to talk about the thing
but one when i went in there i found it
very bizarre
that because i had to kick one of them
out that was the task right yeah so
before i go in i turn up and i'm at this
production
uh shed in the middle of nowhere and
they go right we want you to go in
everyone's being too nice we want you to
put a knife through jmx's football
no no sorry it was kick the football
over the garden or something and there's
a lot
you're always carrying
up i do not remember well i won't be
able to stir up anymore well
everything's amplified in there so he
he really he obviously clearly wanted
them yeah as i was going in
as i was going in they were a pressure
cooker with a load of oxo cubes in it
it was terrible i'll tell you that right
now but as i was going through the door
the guy went by the way
that won't be a task so i went what do
you mean they went you'll just
go in and do it so they're just going to
build into the narrative that i've just
walked in with
see you later so i'm so cute
no i'm not doing it you tell me it's a
task i'll do it yeah but anyway i went
in the task came up and then i had to
kick
out jmx or some other guy that was in
there some guy called jordan
and uh so i it was always planned i was
trying to get
out right jmx had an operation two days
later it was booked in so like yeah
i i knew oh i knew before it started
that joel was only there for a week
what was his operation on his shoulder
or something so i went in and they were
like who are you gonna kick out and i
went oh i played up to it a bit and went
jmx and everyone started [__] crying
i like bambino becky she i feel like i
thought going in she's my friend but
she's crying her eyes out looking at me
oh this is too far i'm like it's a
reality
tv i have my golden moment right
you
what's your favorite meal deal yeah yeah
it's just crazy
loves it loves it um so so yeah they're
all crying and jmx leaves and they're
all looking at me like i'm an absolute
scumbag
and i just went oh think of it this way
at least he'll get a lovely little black
and white montage leaving and one guy
went
no you're enjoying this too much and i
just went everybody
and no one made a sound and becky's
looked at me and gone too far
and i've gone we're in a [__] big
brother
promoting trainers like what have you
seen the way it ends
have you seen the way it ends after the
episode everybody's so angry at jack and
i mean they're not joking they're
living this is really like a scripted
moment where
oh yeah it was part of the show
jmx and all the people on there like
obviously they're trying to remember
their names
and it's a jmx due to leave on the day
that i went in so i was like i'll take a
picture of that right
so the concept like it's it's insane how
can you how close can you go
to someone in it four days and a house
yeah doesn't it just
back these tears they weren't real i
like her i like her but she could have
had my back a little bit more
yeah i do often think that with games
like there was that guy called nasty
nick in the first ever big brother oh he
took a piece of paper and created
called them out oh yeah and everyone was
livid with him and i remember thinking
at the time he's only a piece of paper
like is it really that bad yeah you
started with nasty nick in this
the place i decided with reason stephen
yeah it was really weird
if every time somebody got voted out on
that show it would cut to a picture of
them in black and white with the
right who who died i was like he's not
dead
no one wanted to see him
for an hour oh no is it jd sports or
footer i mean clearly someone uh as you
can see the advertising was
very clear well i mean could you not
tell i'm sure i see in the diary
like because i've seen the diary room at
one point i was like why is there loads
of bags around you like
i mean
branded content though can be done like
one of two ways and when i've seen them
still bags everywhere i was like tacky
you said we're in the gym shark dog
classy i would actually be wearing a
t-shirt i don't sit next to a pile of
bags very much
do you know what i mean
all the microphones are attached to
those like little like funny patterns oh
yeah branded
i don't go anywhere without them yeah
little bags did you know many of the
people when you went in there or was
this a bit like cold do you know what i
mean
becky like i consider her a friend so i
when i was going in i was like i know
her
and ellen and neal had been on my
podcast apart from that who's the
darkest
um
gun she does all the crimes yeah but um
jake mitchell's sister was in there
eloise mitchell sackcliff is so good so
i've made a video about jake mitchell
before like who's jake mitchell just um
he wanted he was like justin bieber back
in the day but now he's like a road man
oh sick flicks the rolly and my stuff
came up yeah check it check him out yeah
but i went in there and she acted like
i'd slaughtered her entire family right
i watched the video back after and they
were all like
jack you don't know what like not to me
this is when i was not there they were
like
jack ruined her entire family it's so
funny like i'd set her out sometimes
i made one video about a little brother
like you walk in don't you
and everybody's in this center room and
jack comes down the stairs
and she wasn't with them forever and she
was the only one who wasn't in the room
and she opens the door and you could see
her over his shoulder
she opens the door by him sees jack her
eyes
but she's very close with some other
people are a bit like it
jeremiah isn't a nazi we don't know what
he was reading anymore
how to be good balls chapter two
take off gerbils we've covered that now
yeah good job
really jmx is reading minecamp
this is the weird thing is we don't have
a problem with any of these people but
it's just funny
so they seem really off often that like
they don't seem like real people to me
they seem like characters don't they and
when they go on a show like this then i
automatically treat them like a
character yeah yeah because i look at
them and i just think well you've
demeaned yourself
yeah it's not realistic you are this to
me i'll be honest i said
i'm well i said i'm not going in
and then they went we'll double double
the fee and i went
i'm not sure and then they went and will
add a bit more on top and i went okay
uh i can't do the two weeks they went
we'll just put you in for the last five
days
so i said to philadelphia i'm basically
just going on a little bit of a holiday
to some
airbnb somewhere she can understand you
going away
you don't have to explain why she's a
dog daddy's going away for a little
while yeah
left for a little meal tell me about
that when i go back
to everything available something like
cheese and pickles yeah and then
yes so 100 of the bag for an hour so who
cares i think i won
yeah i think i'm done who the real
winner was because
exactly i'm pretty sure your hourly rate
was the best buy of the month
in their [__] house the rest of them
yeah sitting in their own filth
yeah you didn't have to stop with the
podcast did you just keep going yeah
yeah what did it smell like it smelled
musky
it smell i can't deal very well with
heat i'm ginger right i went upstairs
into the bedroom
they were all outside no one no
company's in there at this point yeah i
lay on the bed and i can just smell
musk as soon as they come in i went does
it get any cooler in here and they went
no and i was just like i don't know i
can't do this yeah wow
yeah so you cut your visit shop yeah it
was
whatever horrific thing is that you did
congratulations amazing
yeah it was worth it that's for sure
yeah no it wasn't it was there was a
huge
misunderstanding in there okay which
i'll happily tell you all individually
okay can we just hear it as a group of
mike
one by one i know you meant them come on
in
your guys yeah uh but no yeah we'll
we'll move on
who won yeah i won i was in there for an
hour right okay
i really want to know what the fee was
because i remember they they asked me if
i wanted to go in there
and like how about how about this then
how about this how how much would you
have to be paid to go in that house for
an hour i'll tell you i remember you
actually quoting me how much you want
for two weeks oh wait can we hear you
said 250 grand
that's a big price yeah i i literally
said 300 grand or i wouldn't do it i
said it's not worth it you literally
heard his one and went
out
i definitely charge more than alex you
basically go whenever alex is charging
double it and they go especially if i
have to go in there with alex yeah yeah
definitely when you triple it no i said
i just said to them that if they could
they couldn't pay me enough to get in
there
yeah it sounded like a nightmare people
are asking um
most embarrassing sexual moments um
you've really given up for this first
time
i i i did ask for some [__] foot
asylum bed
basically sex and the paul brothers not
not together just a separate topic
um sexy paul brothers if i had to be
spit roasted by the mud go jake front
nug and back
yep other way around no why why why
would you want chase
i just realized that logan is so easy
yeah but that's it i imagine uh logan
sort of got a bigger uh
[__] so yeah yeah yeah so you'd be
choking on it
cheers to that you can knock me out
this is such a weird mental picture just
jab me in the head all day long
yelling timber
what do you think of jake paul's little
message he did to conor mcgregor the
irish flag draped across his back
he knows what he's doing uh genius yeah
absolutely genius i thought
myself uh you're literally forcing well
i mean we're talking about it right now
uh and every fighter immediately
started talk he's like they view him as
the conor mcgregor without the hard
fight bit
they're like payday but i don't actually
have a hard fight
but the problem for everyone else is
that you fight jake
if he's actually kind of good and i
don't really know how good he is yet
because it's like everyone he's fought
deji gibbel
and nate robinson none of them are like
as big as him so he's got a massive
advantage on them straight away
andy's been boxing longer than them so
like yeah he's beaten them
but in my head i'm like it's going to be
so different when he gets in there with
somebody who can actually fight
i don't know what his level is dylan
danis so i think he'd probably
beat dylan dennis in a boxing match
interesting because i saw the clip you
know the clip that came out where he
throws the
toilet paper toilet paper in their water
balloon or something yeah i thought oh
god dylan looks really angry and when
you see it from
i think brendan sharp was interviewing
him yeah yeah yeah dylan dance is just
chilling
he's just like oh this is hilarious he
was laughing he was laughing yeah
he seemed to find it relatively
enjoyable yeah he's quite funny i feel
like dylan's kind of it's a weird one
because if
if he fights jake the whole mma will
have to get behind dylan
but on the other hand mostly mma well
don't like dylan daniels yeah he's the
jake paul
in mma what what what's his game who is
he he's a very good wrestler isn't it
he's uh he's a uh
he's a jiu jitsu guy who mix everyone so
he's not a boxer
but in mma he just takes you down
because he's amazing at
submissions he'll just break your arm so
when he's on the feet he looks
pretty average can you do a tombstone i
can see why
jake would say oh let's but then he he
spawns with conor mcgregor
so he's kind of if he beats the hell out
of conor mcgregor's training partner
yeah
it's just great for him right ins and it
they could make money out of it yeah
what are you laughing at
you just talk about tombstone pal driver
on jake paul oh
yeah did you undertake a retire this
year you know yeah he did that's
about time for about the fifth time yeah
he looked a little bit shaky when he was
fight
he's wrestling he's for the past we've
still got the strength now yeah
bless him he's quite old isn't he yeah
he's getting on
yeah they'll be out of retirement to
fight cal freezing finally
good at boxing then because from what
i've seen and i know nothing about
boxing but he looks [__] decent
he's the best youtube box we've seen i
reckon yeah yeah if you yeah you could
have him
yeah obviously yeah he he looks [__]
good he's the best one who's four
when someone's knocking people out like
that and and hurting them in terms of
the visual yeah for knockout but then
yeah but he hasn't fought jj logan no
who is it bigger guys than what he's for
jj's got the best record to be fair his
raps are good like that well at least
the beats are good yeah
i don't know who writes it's not him
it's not they pay so much money in los
angeles it's like a cheat code
yeah it's not jake paul on the generally
like saying youtubers make their own
music it's like saying like i built this
flat like i mean i'm in the flat
yeah it doesn't mean i [__] made it
no that's what i mean i made my diss
track on man like hack so i'll have you
know
well i'm sure it was your mic
you've just given up and just started
calling it big brother what was it like
when you met the fourth dad
oh great yeah
i'd love to [__] shoot greg though
yeah it was good it was i mean he
threatened to that he threatened to
knock me out
um and that was all right
yeah like you could be like because i
think it's failed someone says they're
going to punch your face
yeah and he seemed pretty [__]
serious yeah
were you a bit like oh [__] this could
actually help him i'll be completely
honest yeah
if that would have been if that had been
anyone else i would have been and i'm
not saying that in terms of like oh i
could have him he could probably knock
me out i don't know i'm not a fighter
but it was a combination of the whole
week that was like our end goal to get
that
to i didn't know i didn't even know if
it turned up to the fight so when i see
him
at first pam logan's mum she was like
yeah
greg's here you can ask him he'll love
this and everything she is lovely
and he's like i'm gonna [__] knock
you out blah blah blah i was thinking
please do i wanted him to land one on me
i'm showing off a little bit as well
because you see all the youtubers
watching i was like this is going to be
a great clip
like i can finally fulfill my dream of
being josh peters right here if this is
if this happened
longer than give to be fair uh yeah
that's true
right that's a very good nice compliment
thank you but you sound like borax
um but yeah no i really wanted him to
hit me in the face and i would i i there
was no element of
and actually i've got to give props to
fiona because i had alfie filming and
fiona and there was one point where he
went turn those [__] cameras off and
alfie went like that and fiona just kept
recording so i was like what a [__]
boss [__] i'm alright you are right
player
yes you are yeah she's a bad baby you're
a boss [__]
we did nearly you wouldn't touch a woman
remember
what no he started do i remember what
happened that night well we did
we nearly got a bit of an altercation do
you remember did you go yeah
yeah i was just an extrovert got thrown
out of the thing no this was when
ben phillips oh i stand up oh bp garage
you know ben phillips is brian
i i've i've spoke to him online before
but i don't i've never met him
his brother always gets one up on him
doesn't it yeah
knocked him out one punch i'll have you
know
he's a big boy what do we mean by all
the kisses me and jack have both done
videos on him who haven't we've done
videos on at this point
and he came up to me he put his arm
around me and i didn't know it was
because i'm
i'm like a lost boy in miami i don't
know what's going on suddenly this bloke
is everybody's twice my size
puts his arm around me i look up and
it's just ben phillips and he just goes
well i love your videos that's not welsh
accent i love your videos bro
i love your videos because i love your
videos and then
and then he looks up at jack he goes
and then oh i just remember they were
going at it and i
beat his arm around me so they're like
having his vote
when you said going at it what roughly
was so we were fake we were
there was verbals and then we were like
quite close and then fiona was having
what does verbals mean though what is it
so so he had a problem with me calling
him out right never got twos upon a
squirrel
ben phillips has yeah yeah he hasn't
stayed at a conway ben phillips
but the first time i met him was that
the fight and we and we had a very
heated
altercation and uh sorry so so ben
phillips is a hard man what really
happened was they
he turned up and then his brother turned
up and i just remember
him glued to his face
like 2013 they did a lot of facebook
pranks like honestly i have no [__]
ideas okay so he used to use this thing
i've washed your pants and i've put them
on the side and they put them on there
but he put like itching powder in them
and he'd be like
bro it burns and things like that and
then he'd be like what have you done
like if i was his brother i just
wouldn't trust him
you start to think maybe it's not real
yeah
my favorite one they did was when he he
tricked him to get into the back of a
van
they closed it and just drove off and
he's just i mean
we put like slippery liquid all over the
back of the house
he's just bouncing around wow and you
think that is real
yeah but he's gone i'll do it why not
they must have made so much money though
oh yeah you can't knock how much money
these people make like
you can this julius julius dean guy that
i've had who's that he's in the facebook
machine i've met him
i've met all these people there's two
things i don't like facebook and
magicians
yeah there you go there you go you're
not into magicians
we're not one of those kids that we do
not remember the last time i said that
thing about david blaine we had
all these [__] magicians messaging
with oh what stephen mulhern
i just said basically i
rather watch someone who can like sing
or i is athletically gifted
for me that is actual talent yeah
whereas doing tricks
there's something like i've seen one
i've seen them all like i don't
i can't keep watching that and finding
it close-up magic in real life is
interesting because you're like because
you know the trick in you but it's like
oh i didn't actually see how they did it
i get that when you watch a video yeah
and david blaine of all people when he's
freezing himself under the road
but the rest of them weren't real i mean
what
did you see that yeah oh it's unreal but
also the
the terrible thing is the the balloon
isn't even that good he's just holding
on to some balloons
he's not even holding on he's harnessed
in and he's made it look like he's
holding on
yeah and then he eventually unclips
himself and that's it
yeah but i mean fair enough it looked
pretty cool but all i was just saying
was like you know
if i could watch you saying bolt run 100
meters or [__]
a great singer go to me that's like
talent like i get that there's talent in
doing magic but i just find it a bit uh
you know i strongly
i strongly disagree you're going to
regret this if you're if you're a
magician and you're over the age of 20
it's time to grow up
i'm
[Music]
and i actually made friends with an
asian woman and i was sat next to her
and she tried to hook me up with her
daughter she showed me a picture saying
do you like my daughter do you like my
daughter i know i've got her on
instagram and she's here right now
we have a little chat was she asking you
what your job prospects were and stuff
like that she what do i reckon so much
she just kept showing me a picture
saying do you like her do you like her
and i was like yeah she's all right
what am i supposed to do
so wait a minute you you stayed in
contact with this woman i
was on a train i sat next to her i was
steaming after the podcast
okay if you've been seeing me for the
whole year and that's why you're
celebrating
i don't understand what they're watching
yeah
that's my mom yeah but so so i'm on the
train yeah two little
kids coming after you right but everyone
else on the train
you got them on facebook as well what's
that nothing can we get more booze
oh it's here i ignore that i don't even
know what you mean what do you mean like
can you cut me out saying more malware
you went two kids came to take a picture
of me and i went do you have them on
facebook as well
it was instagram this was never a good
snapchat is the one it's awful no it's
great oh people love it
why are you watching us it's christmas
day these people are very lonely people
it's been a difficult year brian tell me
about
she's good thank you she's working now
oh
thank [__] for my bank account is she on
twitch as well is she
she's not now she yeah she only twitches
when i uh give her the good stuff
oh as in sexual lovers yeah not drugs is
[Applause]
[Music]
she's she's a lovely girl i'm surprised
it's like she stood
up say me you know same here brian
because i'm an annoying [__] that's what
i was thinking this is it
she's she's a star for staying with me
but
no she's lovely my thing about you has
always been the same
thing like the idea of being in a
relationship with you is
at what point there's a lot at what
point because if you hang around stephen
the jokes never stop at what point
before having sex do the joke stop or
does it just continue or does she laugh
while he's coming do you
do you literally what's coming
do you carry up the like the
light-heartedness or is there a moment
where it goes no
there's a genuine problem here brian
because the whole aspect of
the idea of sexy talk is something i
struggle with so much
when you're trying to be funny and then
you have to be she was like
what's the sexiest thing you've ever
said oh no don't look her up what was
she like i want to hear this she's like
you know she was like
just she wanted me to talk because i was
silent when we had sex
when it first started this is it because
you know living at home with my mum yeah
silent wank was
the way to go yeah christine
sorry no no just just in general when i
when i first had sex
i didn't i didn't make a noise she was
like were you looking her in the aisle
we finally got onto the awkward sexual
stories not with those tits laurence
yeah
so she wanted a bit of sexy talk yeah
and i really struggled my voice isn't
sexy
it is actually all right uh but yeah
unfortunately it was always a scathing
performance
it's terrible your form is waffle
but your jets are fantastic they're too
on top of doing videos
you slowly progress with it as you get
more comfortable with each other
but it's i'm bad at being sexy it's not
me you do i
i feel like i'd like like taught you
more about it don't they say though if
you can make a woman laugh you can
make her well absolutely but there is a
time to stop the love
steve the problem is steven's still
playing to the room when they're having
sex so he's like am i right
okay
no but you haven't done well you have
lusted this is it yeah
probably fair that's not what she said
about him what's the sexiest no no
that's the bedroom
you know there's good and then there's
terrible
the scale can slide this is it yeah it's
like a [__] windscreen
do you ever read back the stuff that
you've said and go [__] sake yeah
no yeah no it's always it's always
terrible if we were to
yeah everybody everybody's done when
you're not in the mood yourself and
you're reading out like
yeah and then i will do it it never
sounds good
it never does when you're watching porn
and you've come and it's like oh
sometimes you look at them
the minute you come it doesn't matter
what you are watching you never think
that's still good
or if you catch yourself in a reflection
just before it's [__] horrible smooth
mirror
oh ben phillips put the scroll down i
had some girl ask me once to
to to uh say something
dirty fiona no it actually wasn't um oh
right
and uh i've never done that i've not
been a dirty talker
yeah and she's this close to me and she
said it's your favorite meal deal
so she's like she's there you're like i
don't know yeah and she's like
speak dirty to me she knows this anyways
she knows what you're saying
thousands of people yeah
so i said i didn't
brought this up
so i went spit in my mouth and she went
she went that's [__] disgusting
see i've got a story about that so i was
about 18 19
and i was with a girl who was like way
more experienced than me
yeah and i'm on top of her and i'm like
i'm doing my best but
she was way too much woman for me to be
honest like
at that age though like she was like 25
she was bigger
like stone she was not she was
they're they're sticky girls no i'm not
even gonna
she was a very much a plus sized woman
and at that age i just didn't have the
experience yeah a lot yeah so it's just
nothing funny i'm doing my best
this is it and then she's like spit in
my mouth and like i'm just like
i don't know i think you started rapping
no no right that was jazz
genuinely though i was just like did you
do it i did but it was the most pathetic
like
yeah what they want when they say that
are they talking proper
how much did you how much phlegm was in
it not nothing was it a thimble full
it was it was literally just like a
little spit like it wasn't yeah
much but then how do you really say i
think i need to start looking for
different girls
this is it yes so sorry how did that
work like you know um
like in in in logistics wise how did
that work did you then bend over and go
no what i'm saying is missionaries
in missionary and she's asking for it
right in her face in her mouth
yeah and i'm just saying
i guess i'm not saying lad but this is
the thing
that was all for what 11 years ago yeah
obviously like
have you had that since that request um
is it going to take a bit of remember uh
i don't know
off the top might remember but it's not
like yeah the most
unusual thing that women have asked for
but at the same time i just like
i don't know it's yes when you first
start trying to talk to you in that it
is a bit of a like
it's horrible it's [__] horrible you
feel a bit self-conscious yeah i'm over
that now quite clearly but
i'm not a very confident man in the
bedroom by any means but yeah no
god no look at me i'm not i've not got
it you're quite
physically attractive though
you've gotta give it a go we should be
the best at this this should be
it doesn't matter what dick size you got
how strong you are what you what
positions you good at
you we should all be good at talking
dirty really oh no stick a canon 80d in
my face and i find it easy right real
woman
no way
you've got the equipment you know how it
works what do you mean stick a can of
whatever
cannon a camera
level one amateur
you seem like a very dirty texter oh uh
yeah i swear yeah i could agree with
that i wouldn't want those on the
internet
i will put them on screen now yeah i'll
send him over and post
um no i say i i i actually became single
this year okay
so it's been it's been a great year do
you prefer single life to
oh this is gonna be really sad sorry is
that why you've been posting a lot of
like
topless since there's been a lot of
pictures as well for alex has sort of
snapped back he's flaunting it a little
bit at the moment
he's great break up you when you have a
glow up right this is it yeah
when's it coming yeah yeah i waited i've
[Music]
you can be a little bit critical of the
other person
yeah i don't know if that makes sense
are you gonna need to go into this a bit
no but like you've been over that laptop
all day yeah
i always have to do the dishwasher why
don't you ever join in
no but i just like because yeah you
[__] love that don't you like that
sort of [__]
this is pretty cool when you're in the
mountains it's a little easy it's too
easy to come
yeah yeah you [__] love that right do
you like when someone else says things
about you
oh yeah yeah yeah how how far can
someone go before it gets too much
and you begin to lose the erection i
personally say
good luck you know what i mean yeah push
it as hard as you can
right because like you know come on do
you exchange like do you exchange like
team quests before before sex as well
yeah i could see who breaks first
you're gonna get this yeah gobbledygook
yeah
to be fair uh there's it's less cordial
than the man city man united derby
oh that was a little different too
friendly for me
i want it nasty yeah yeah let's get
nasty i want glasgow rangers
yeah that's why i want scott browner for
my dick yeah lauren so you what are you
like in the bedroom sir
well obviously i'm a reasonable level
because i've achieved something very big
this year
right well not allowed to put there
anonymous name congratulations to
uh
[Music]
how did that happen worked that out for
yourself that was that was an incredible
day at
shoreditch the next week when we turned
up and everybody went as long as you got
a kid now yeah
never mentioned that yeah uh and that
just happened it was also through
lockdown so it was sort of like
we did what else to do no no like we we
conceived the child before lockdown
it's not a lockdown baby so uh and
yeah that was i feel so long ago now
like you almost you know weirdly you
can't imagine now
not having that yeah baby yeah yeah so
you can't really
think of it i cried when he facetimed me
yeah i faced some duke brian like an
hour after the birth and he was on the
train back
i was [__] from london and he was
just like wow it's just
so beautiful oh i love people
here yeah someone's had a child is is a
lovely moment
it was very fast as well yeah what do
you mean by fast it was like three years
the baby was like very quick so it may
be good though isn't it
yeah but i was like i was ready to like
bed in i've told the story in another
box i was like
yeah okay we'll be here for like 10
hours or something you were saying i've
got the kickoff at 10 come on
he messaged me at like 7 a.m when i
think the baby's coming
and i messaged back like i was like
don't forget everything you've done you
know everything's going to be fine
trusted everything
and he just replied yep and i was like
oh [__] he's panicking but he was fine
we were chilling actually like weirdly
we were just it was so chill
yeah really well what were you doing the
day
that that all kicked off sleeping it was
like
5am when it all kicked off oh wow and
then um
literally it was just like oh baby's
coming okay cool time it
yeah yeah we should probably go to
hospital and he's he's so laid back
generally i'll be sharing with you laid
back when you conceived the baby
[Music]
probably
i've seen those uh hip thrusts though
you did good work sir i'm very powerful
man
um is abducted as a great i've seen you
a center back at shoreditch i know all
about that
yeah sadly i feel bad about tackling you
because i
i'm so much heavier than you that i can
let you just go yeah and i fly
you just go yeah this is why i can't
come to shoreditch yeah this is laurence
is a big heavy guy though
yeah that's meant me well i'm at the
third of the three
there's einab is obviously you know a
pretty big guy right
not in the youtube world though because
the e-boys
good snakes good yeah
you'll love that when you say christmas
watching i actually like that i know
do you think he realized this year was
bisexual because he's been hanging out
with you for quite a while he's known
he's known for a while no i
he to be honest actually came out
to me before i was out how many of the
boys are bisexual uh all of them when
i'm done with them
jesus that's a good statement would you
say the e-boys is a success
i would yes i would i would a million
subscribers is a success especially
because
we started it in lockdown good old
lockdown
i was trying to [__] it [__] it all
honestly [__] corvid foot locked down
yeah see how many cases there were today
how many financial services were also
around the table
35 000. what in the uk okay
i'm done it's all it's because everybody
is getting tested to go home right
so obviously everybody's going to be
getting tested i got a test i'm i'm
negative by the way
what about cody the only time i've come
back no those are positive
if you're not like positive i'm going to
go in on the politics and all but let's
be honest
they've [__] it right up so if they
can't get it right
i'm not going to worry anything about
dominic come pants you know what i mean
they're [__]
and if there's still thinking that
they're doing the right thing
and believing when one minute it's you
know to help out the next minute
oh everyone shut down
because this is our job and there is a
thing that the government did release
saying that video shoot days are still
allowed
by a camera hang out with your mates
this is it
easy the thing is right we're actually i
think genuinely youtube and twitch and
all those kind of platforms are
currently keeping people from going
completely insane
oh yeah hitting a million subscribers
didn't you very true yeah
yeah yeah yeah well remembered cheers
you got to be cheers in life that's what
i think you have but also you think i've
put on that much content you've not
subscribed
[__] off [__] yourselves
we've been waiting on two million for a
while now but we haven't really gone
for like yours to get more subs yeah i
think will does really well
he casts the net out all the time he's
got his head switched on do you know
what i mean i don't
um yeah i do i do videos where i think
if i look back in three years
it'll still be on there and still be
relevant whereas will has got this
he's got the way to work it and he knows
what he's doing
did she oh somebody shouldn't send me
she sent him a call
she follows me on twitter i've told jack
that before but uh i don't know where
that came it was an incredible day
it's a boyfriend who's shocked another
day isn't it yeah yeah
yeah you liked i met i met i met her
boyfriend what do you like honestly he's
he's alright what a simp or whatever no
no he's actually a very like normal
like nice guy but but like there was a
little bit of belledale fiending him to
the point where he
thought the other way he came wearing an
ash ketchum hat
is that the pokemon from pokemon so he
wore that so he's like he's a he's a
very good looking guy very normal is he
very good
this is the thing yeah i don't know like
if if i have to say who
the male i'm most attracted to i'd go
for like your typical male answer
chris md beckham or pravee cooper surely
that's jackie
is crying right now
when he was doing the meet and greets
for 500 quid i said he's doing a contour
oh very good i'll drink to that yeah
that was funny
i wouldn't block you for that i retweet
you for that yeah yeah well that's
because you've got away
james james back then probably not yeah
james how many times have you james
charles off
my every time i see him it's mental so
how many times have you seen him
he does look kind of like a woman when
he dresses up or like womanly
if that's the only time it's acceptable
for me right i say when you're a man
get out because when a woman says to you
suck this [__] you think that's
acceptable
yeah i'm forgetting what we move and
talk about talking about things
so what was your boyfriend like so was
he similar to her demeanor because
and what i also want to know is does he
talk like a young person as well though
no he he's got his brains like he's got
his he's got his head screwed on like
but his head's on his body yeah i
thought i thought he
i'm allowed to say this because i'm an
ugly [__] but i thought he was an
average looking guy
right but fiona was like no he's he's
he's up there so
really was he good looking fee was he
really yeah what are we talking about
six or seven five
no no no no no because i'm gonna put
this in context
so this means all these mugs who think
they could actually [__] bell delphi
might have a point
no yeah but his personalities attend
probably he he knew very little about
youtube i was shocked at how little
he really liked it why is her platform
is it only fans yeah she makes a lot of
money on only fans but
they're talking seven figures she's got
a big youtube like instagram she's all
over the place but he
knew so little it baffled me but yeah
he's the guy
in the video a lot of people keep
thinking it's going to be jj
because obviously he saw it that was the
people
yeah but people were thinking bell had a
boyfriend who she kept off camera and he
had a girlfriend
one-on-one together but obviously it's
not he's just playing up to it because
it works well for both
do you think he's going to look good
naked who could be
their boyfriend he was like an all-right
guy like nothing he wouldn't blow
he wouldn't blow he wouldn't i wouldn't
spit in his mouth okay all right
that's what i'm trying to say so that
there we will leave it
did you have a sexy vibe in the room
because to me i i the problem for me is
i'm not attracted to
her no so i don't see her as a sexual
sort of person i can understand why
someone might hear a sexual
but it doesn't take any of my boxes i
like your type
i'm the same i'm the same i think she
doesn't
i don't know who she appeals to but she
she presents herself as being quite
young
surely you'd say pedophiles it was what
you mean jack
we're talking about prince andrews at
the moment yeah it is a bit weird though
because
on the one hand she's clearly a woman
yeah but the person that's on the other
hand
is quite immature she's very anime yes
and the voices are very squeaky and
deliberate online yeah but when you were
like childish she hires somebody to do
the voice i mean joe pasquale had a
squeaky voice she wasn't [__] bro
he was thick
when you look at her in the videos you
think like she's got womanly curves and
she's got a big bum on her and all of
that like
so are you saying you're low ender
low-key attracted to no
how do i put this of course she's
clearly an adult she's not really
she has things about her that you you
think of as a man you'd look at angles
sorry like
but then the position if she put the
persona on during
that moment you'd be a bit like this is
[__] weird i think the persona is
more intimidating than the person yeah
like when you meet her like she doesn't
act
young and kooky in all of this
[Music]
the reason why i talk about it she goes
viral in a way that a lot of people just
don't like
similar to me it's kind of weird how
many people have seen her yeah
yeah like that six nine videos she made
yeah i haven't seen
i just can't stop watching this this is
[__] weird yeah
yesterday i ordered an uber from
football i love it
right i ordered an uber for football for
for me and my two mates
so you know you have to do multiple
stops anyway so we ordered it
he pulls up into the car park on the
edge and he goes i can't take you
what so we come to we come to the edge
of the carpet i think he can't come in
here because he's got to turn
so i go uh and he goes yeah i can't take
it you're dirty and smelly
oh what he goes you're dirty and smelly
i'm not taking you wow because you're
covered in mud and we're like we're on
astroturf but
we're completely clean and he goes all
right then get in
so go sorry dirty and smelly and he goes
yeah i go imagine if i called you dirty
and smelly
and he's like he's like just get in the
car i'm going no piss off
wow i was so living that dirty and
smelly was he foreign
yes but you're saying it's lost in
translation for me it may have been this
is where he's going
this is my scouse mother coming into oh
god don't say that again stephen
this is my mother coming to be going
going
i'm not i'm not getting a lift for free
here i'm paying you for this service
don't see me from 10 meters ago dirty
and smelly [__]
even though you nailed it right i think
he might have meant something else he
was probably just foreign
he got him got it wrong no because i
kept questioning him about it brian
he kept going with it yeah he double
down dirty and smelly did you get
another driver
yeah who's ironically his name is
mudasir wow who's had mud in his name
was he foreign no
some of them can be good people he went
for the next adjective smelling to be
fair if you're a while away you don't
know whether
how smelly someone is quite close to
that person
yeah he didn't know that though who do
you think smells best on youtube
i'll tell you what the doll smells good
as a little bit
yeah yeah i always go for the same one
am i my barber went to me
what's the after i have to shave your
smell i thought he was getting her you
know a little hint
anyway yeah it gives me a headache
you know i just don't watch youtube
anymore i'm just gonna say this that's
why i couldn't pick somebody this year i
generally
would you watch it anymore are you
that's why i can't make videos
yeah this is why victoria june's
cancelled
i'll tell you what we need to stop lisa
tell me who i do enjoy watching
a guy called tim dillon right um
the comedian the community in fake
tim dillon is this he is he is such a
good comedian i'm going to have to
follow his american yeah but he's not
american and humor
no you're huge like he's very outrageous
yeah he will say the thing
i think you'll love him yeah he's been
my favorite new discovery online that's
good
really funny guy he was on joe rogan's
podcast
with alex jones the last time oh yeah
did you see the
so joe rogan did uh kanye west but
what i saw was the clips of joe rogan
before kenya west came on just
saying what dick eddie was i know it's
like but the uh
we've all had that moment though where
we absolutely come face to face with
someone who we've probably said some
things that our bodies
every single week
whether or not you could punch someone's
face in or not really it's more just
like uh
until you meet the person yeah yeah
you've got this you get an exaggerated
view of somebody
he goes the other way though like i had
the f2 you thought they were
gods yeah i think if anything yeah you
played do you know what was mental is
when that that video came out i'd
forgotten all about what we never
mentioned it
when it all happened we were actually
trying to take exo quite seriously we
were like
look do we really need this [__] right
now let's just focus on us
and let it go but then when you told the
story on jack's podcast
i was like oh yeah that did happen did
you the
the thing with that when the
so i told that story about 20 times but
to just like
people have come up to me and they
they're going about stuffing like the
wembley cup
and i go in again like talk about that
story like what let me talk about jeremy
lynch yeah so i
so basically on that day i remember i
came to you didn't i when he was
he's just been a knobbed uh my main
regret about that
is when they came over with the cameras
i sort of took it seriously
it was if i'd just be like i imagine
nico or molana would have taken the piss
in that scenario
and just well do you know what was funny
i really didn't think that they would
take the diss track that stephen did
seriously so much so that
when they came around our table at the
start of the day i was like
mate you got to say the the diss track
he did on you this is hilarious to be
fair that is on camera
i literally said oh you're gonna laugh
you're gonna laugh when you see the
video i literally had
no idea that anyone would take that
seriously no for a start i'm pretty sure
were you dressed up as batman at one
point yeah max was yeah
well clearly you can't confuse us i
thought the f2 lads would find it funny
yeah
i just i genuinely did it was because
they couldn't laugh at themselves
that that is why he has become a meme
now yeah he'd have just come out and
gone
yeah i was a bit of a [__] stephen your
video was funny then there would not be
me no the worst thing is the video was a
gift though
he mugs in the game they won the game
they won the tournament yeah
you you can't you can't ask for anything
more also clearly the implied joke was
yeah
they'll they are obviously the better
footballers that's it obviously
even if you're gonna destroy us are they
very nice
i said we'll beat you i said we'll beat
you at wembley by cheating we lost to
wembley
egg on my face but still that wasn't
enough for him and it wasn't just us he
was going around the hashtag lads i've
been over this before
but uh spencer has done about four times
in my head so i didn't i didn't say
anything because i was like
it's been done now everyone's seen the
video whatever when spencer
this is it when the nicest guy on
youtube who i've like
you literally dissed him on his own
stream and he still said nothing yeah
like when he does a video on you you're
[__] up yeah yeah this is it
yeah i've got an edge to me but i'm a
nice person at the macor
but there there was something about that
day that
like genuinely for about a year it irked
me whenever i thought whenever i had to
get angry
if i was going for a run i had to sprint
i'd think about that moment and i'd just
go for it
it's weird because of me when i watched
that video back i thought myself like
when because i grabbed my arm around you
yeah and i took you out you see my eyes
lighting up when you come in
you like the car the thing is brian i
say anything i knew you were in the
vicinity and i'd
i knew you were going to come over at
some point it was so strange i knew you
were coming at some point
and i was like i've got an ace up my
sleeve
so funny i think my dad's partner got
you and zoe someone came and told me
enough yeah
yeah but you're [__] boss in that
video though this is the thing that's
amazing i don't mean this
i'm glad i had my like calm head on yeah
absolutely because
when i walked away he mouse off
something and then and luckily we were
like probably out the door at that point
but if i'd heard that i think i probably
would have liked it
was a good influence on you like yeah i
was worried about my dad kicking off and
my dad's my dad's not you
my dad's you know he's he's a hard man
he was doing
he was doing buddies when i watched back
yeah but he was doing the perfect thing
just taking the piss out of them they
can't use that footage that they were
trying to get
but that would have been that would have
been the way to go but then part of it
isn't it's weirdly they've managed to
sort of section that off and make that
like
the the mainstream or the the agencies
those sort of people don't know about
that sort of stuff so it must come as a
real surprise
so like they don't know they just i
don't know if you realize
how many comments were there like seven
and a half thousand joe tomlinson must
have had to bit his tongue because he
was there at the
the day and you know it's you you don't
come across well
it is i i will cut them some stuff in
the regards of at some point everyone
around this table
when you get a bit of youtube fame you
take it a bit too seriously absolutely
and yeah everything you're a bit billy
big bollocks but there comes a point
where you go alright
this is actually i'm getting used to
this now but i just think that that
moment didn't come
for too long yeah and uh
if i could have i'd like to have jeremy
on the podcast to go over it but i just
don't think
he'd put himself in that position but i
think actually it would be the best
thing he could do
to go you know what it is he has what
happened to me he has why i acted the
way i did and he has why i'm sorry
there's so many questions about him
isn't there the whole arsenal vibe
and when he got like kicked out of the
academy that's a meme in itself isn't it
the best
best player on the ball that's that's
the biggest meme out of it
i think there's some times in life where
we've all had rejections we've all had
knockbacks
holding your hands up and go yeah i just
wasn't good enough he just doesn't have
the humility but yeah i do think you get
to a certain point well life brings that
to you steve
right like you know i've had those
moments many many times before youtube
in youtube after i'm sure it'll keep
happening but like
when you get humbled yeah it's actually
a really good thing for you sometimes
it's always about you it's also there
are elements which you don't need to be
brought down you just need to
have a sense of perspective on it yeah
so like even this year in having a son i
was like [__] how's he gonna think of
me in this time and i think he's going
to have to eat
he's going to get to top top he's going
to get to a point where he goes
all right what was dad like and someone
at the point where you
realize what that person is what i was
like is when you think how would someone
else describe me
not how would i say i am to that other
person but how would someone else go
he was this or he was that like in two
generations time how's someone gonna go
yeah
who's this guy in this picture here like
what was he like and i think he'll reach
a point in his life where he goes
[__] like i've really what what bad are
you worried if your son asked robbie
from af tv
i mean you say that but robbie and i are
actually on really good terms he said it
on a live stream that long ago really
yeah well we haven't spoken since but he
did say he's got mad respect for lauren
so yeah wow
i actually i'm getting to a point where
i don't really want youtube beef
beef isn't worth it
the anxiety that comes with it you want
to make videos log off and cash
financially financially though honestly
yes like even with jeremy
you know to be honest i actually thought
it was that it was
it was jeremy's mate who come across as
the biggest bell end in that video but
even
yeah i think there's a mum we all accept
that the kids talented and he's got a
lot of things
to yeah yeah he's right very successful
because i look at jeremy and i've spoke
to a lot of people and i go but i
i like i don't think lester i mean kevin
was a dick but i don't think we did was
like
oh get rid of jeremy lynch i think the
problem with
the problem is for jeremy is over the
years there were so many times where
little things like that had happened to
so many different people that he'd been
on shoots with and the little things
and they mount up and eventually a whole
group of people went
should we should we just get him yeah
and that's basically what happened
the chickens came on the [__] roof
for the kids
the healthiest thing you can do in that
moment is actually go
i've got to get a handle on this and
address it and actually accept what i've
done and go you know what it is
i've been a bit of a dick i'm i'm
learning from this and now i realize we
have gone wrong
that's what happened i think when when
the mistake he made was sweeping it
under the carpet and hoping it would go
away yeah and to say
in that sky commenting uh all those
thousands of people being like
there's jazz shaggy's out here already
all these comments
it's because you have you haven't left
it yourself
[Applause]
take this on it's over yeah thank god
you let me roast you
yeah of all people oh they didn't say
that yeah yeah but yeah
you handled that perfectly through that
[__] like
like yeah i actually made that choice
jeremy lynch is still in that
eight-year-old mindset where he cannot
laugh at himself and i'm sorry if you
sit there if you sit there with your
mate bill and goes
oh arsene wenger said i was one of the
best on the ball what the [__] are you
on about
you've got that you've got to follow up
with a joke anyway because the thing is
i don't necessarily doubt that that
story is true
he's a youth player and you'd like to
hope that arsenal football club
at least back then so that's some hope
no not anymore i think
it's politics in order to make them feel
better
but to then repeat that and not look
back and realize why they were saying
that to you yeah i've also really
thought that bro
you'd be there that's what happened to
me they said i was the best player in
the world
really well i actually had some good
chats with jazz like at times and i got
on with them and i thought you know
yeah you wrote people up the wrong way
sometimes but yeah there's likeable
things about his personality it's so
true when you're like one-on-one with
him
yeah he can't be likeable but can't
anyone no
yeah and but they can they can they
can't they're all these stories
you need to get your hands around the
situation or or i guess all just
continue doing what the [__] you're
doing i mean if you meet
some people just think i'm making money
i'm winning [__] everyone
i don't care what they think and
actually maybe he's got the right idea
in that regard but
i think knowing his ego he won't like
that and he he
and i i've got an ego i wouldn't like i
wouldn't like people continuously
ripping the piss out of me but they're
only doing it because they think
it really bothers you people want their
peers to remember them well
they want the people who are around them
and in their industry to go
yes this guy did something well they
don't want to be followed by
these silly rumors because they realize
that at some point someone
in someone in time will look back do
some research and find you
and go why and one day we'll have that
jack
so like i think like
i brought you in to make it easier okay
we we all got into youtube at
like a young age some younger than
others and and we've we've all [__]
up so much because of that it would be
good if like
ariana jazz spencer me
and any one of the people involved that
could sit around and be like
[__] me can i tell you that won't it why
don't we make this a public invite to
get
chairs on the true journey i don't know
i think he'd be
i generally think if he came out and
just spoke about honestly
if he came out as gay it would be great
now i think he i think he'd instantly
turn the tides
i i know you would but because i've seen
the vulnerable side of him
in chat but it's about just having a
bravery and be like
i was going to say everybody i know
everybody i know who works for him now
only says really positive things no [__]
off
no they do you cough i know i know
people you need to sort of discuss
sports
i know people that like work behind the
scenes with like
clothing companies and big brands and
when i when
when you came on the podcast and we've
all spoken about it and i made that
video about hacks
i've had so i've never ever had so many
um
messages jeremy lynch is actually a
prince i messaged him
i messaged jack straight away yeah i was
like he's such a knob
yeah i've never it's all right for us to
do it we might have something to gain
i've been known in the past which i
regret now but calling people out
because i know it's gonna boost my
profile right
these people that work for these top
companies that are behind the scenes
that no one knows who the [__] they are
they have nothing to gain message of me
going i'm so glad you made that video
because he's a prick
one of the people people might be able
to work this out i don't care but one of
the people i know closely who's one of
the nicest people in the world
so said that uh said that he worked
with him and and and he and he just
wasn't a nice guy and i could repeat the
stories here but it wouldn't be fair to
him but
if someone like that is saying that if
someone like that is saying it you need
to take a good hard look
i think and i think when you're in front
of the camera and this is something
people don't
usually admit so i'm going to admit it
anyway you start thinking
you're better than what you are or
whatever it can get a hold of you out of
nowhere you got all these people telling
you [__] great
i love your videos brian all this [__]
and sometimes it does penetrate your
your mind because how can you not you're
just a person
and sometimes that just gets it gets
away from you and you you start thinking
i'm [__] great all right and you know
because
without self belief well why the [__]
wouldn't have been where i am in the
first place
with people reinforcing that it can turn
you into a bit of an [__]
and you know you get humbled rained in
whatever happened
that's all right it's quite poetic that
you're you're going on this tirade and
there's a picture of tony montana
that's like literally like the script of
scarface
yeah the thing about young footballers
is it's such a
it's just strange mentality for them i
don't know if you've heard that story
recently about how that young kid was
released from a football club
it's so sad isn't it that's i think
you're somebody's horrible
they have their whole life built into
this like i am going to be a footballer
one day when they get that removed from
them
sometimes the worst can happen and other
times you know
jazz for example got a second win
absolutely found his working at the
table in the street and that's it
he is so successful he's more successful
than most footballers
you've got to get it generally generally
he really is he's absolutely smashing it
and the thing is with young footballers
if they get you know kicked back at 16
jamie vardy what was he 22 when he even
later in life he came to the premier
league he's one of the best premier
league strikers we've seen
it's a it's a strange world for them
well that's where that bournemouth joke
came from with the whole i play for
warmth because alex you're not gonna be
in the premier league
again because my my mate might because
it came from the fact that my mates
played for bournemouth and
every single one of them got knocked
back it was like every year a new one
got released i had about three mates who
played for him
and they all were convinced they were
going to be footballers and now they
will work at the pub
you've got to be though haven't you you
have to be yes well you're going to tell
us
your parents drill it into you but then
also like what does that do for somebody
which is why when i saw that when i see
that clipping below the best on the ball
player that's him
still trying to convince him if he took
the piss out of himself it'll be over
but can i can i ask a question here and
i'm
genuinely want to know your opinion on
this right so the man like hack stuff
right yeah we all know what he did
and we all know that he's a [__]
writer we all know the uh kind of
kickback that he got from that like i
made a piss take video you was in it
uh lost i i i think like i think
like i think it was a funny video right
but a couple of weeks relatively until i
was in it yeah
yeah that was that was the best bit i'll
give you that but a couple of weeks
later so we're in the pub
me and stevie and bristol and i [__]
myself and i'll be honest and i don't
mind this staying in i want to know your
opinion like
we sorry did you actually [__] yourself
no
he means his jeans people think oh jack
mate calls people out doesn't care like
i do care i don't want anyone to [__]
like loathe you yeah like i do care what
people think of me especially in the
space but
i we get sent this um instagram story
from my mate shafer bates the
impressionist and he was like
have you seen what hacks has put on his
story so hacks and if you saw it but he
put on his story
um quite a powerful video of him crying
in the car
and he was like oh this just keeps
happening to me i'm not that person
anymore
so i want to know he was obviously a
[__] he threatened to [__] stab
someone at a
football of a youtube football event at
what point can you
not take the piss out of someone in the
worry that they're gonna
do something to them can i just say does
that make sense can i just say
hacks uh hacks dm me saying
he was sorry about what happened i dm'd
with about four messages back saying
um you know i accept your apology thank
you for that
i don't think either of us came across
how we want to on that day yeah he never
he never replied to that so that's what
makes me think you know is it just an
apology for apology's sake
yeah i'd say i'd say if he's a comedian
yeah like myself i regret how i came
across that day
because i did i shouldn't have taken
them seriously and you weren't as funny
as you could have been
that's it you never is i didn't enjoy
the line about um
how many retweets you guessed right i
said 100 likes yeah i've done my
research
um but you know it's it was far too
egoy yeah absolutely i think come across
well in that i see what you're saying
though
but if he's i get that he can be funny
i i see that well comedy subjective i
think it's a
[__] shite absolutely but regardless
a wig in an accent you know but i i do
see the comedy aspect to him
and if he wants to be funny absolutely
go for it but you can't take yourself so
seriously you can't
you can't be the enforcer at a [__]
challenge you know the issue is
is that he will have people on his side
going and we should apologize i mean
you'll have people going
[__] steven trump he deserved it and
then he'll be there he'll send you the
apology and he'll be like
i don't know i don't want to go further
because i want to make it seem like i'm
a big [__] yeah and
then it will just i mean it hits this
weird stalemate where you don't
really know what's going on can i just
say like i've got i've got no bad blood
with it because it was it was done and
it's done
like it's a [__] challenge really
funny all the videos are really fun this
is it
not all of them big views um even james
all cop
uh like i said but i i uh
it's a joke that definitely wasn't funny
but my issue was was that
if he's the comedian on their team and i
knew he was
and that's why what on the coach there
he shouted something out and i went oh
he's doing one of his characters
i was just putting him down just because
it was comedian to comedian that was my
idea yeah
same level i was trying to get one up on
him but if
if he's gonna be the enforcer you can't
at the end of a match when you've won
come over and be could be like i'll
shank you mate yeah you can't
do that no no no no if it adds up that's
that's part of that's it
i got i got mugged off by jeremy in the
game he should have been like what
happened to you in the football match
and i came over when he came over to me
i was laughing i was like
oh he's mugged me off here because i've
done a diss track
and they've just [__] beat us and
then when he comes on with that aspect
and they shank me i came to lawrence
because i was like i need someone to
back me up i don't know what to do here
this is ridiculous
and then it came to brian i was like
brian was being interviewed i came over
to him i was like
brian this lad's he's just threatened to
shank me yeah i don't know what's going
on you can't be a part-time comedian in
this slide you have to be a comedian the
whole
this is this is this is the very
definition of part-time
yeah full-time [__] yeah
like so if somebody does something that
we consider bad like the shanking thing
then someone makes a comedy video
let's not just skirt around the issue
here what we're talking about is if that
person then takes that personally they
become a meme online
and then they hurt themselves who is to
blame there like can you
because we get to a point where then you
can't call anyone out for doing anything
that's part of the problem isn't it it's
like there's none of personal
responsibility
right which everyone has to take right
yeah but i also think some people think
can then
take it too far so it goes the other way
but i also think you have to be willing
to stand up for
the cons you have to be willing to be
there for the consequences of what
you've done
not everything has to be all like
sunshine and rainbows
in your size yeah and the problem is i
think there's a lot of people who do
also want to say like well that video is
the definitive video video of yours
well like let's go through anyone's
career anyone's back catalogue
you'll see evolution and your stuff
you'll see evolution and also if you see
evolution in everyone's stuff the
problem is everyone wants to nail you to
that one video and go in that one moment
you made that mistake and that's you now
yeah and it's not
and frankly like it's none of any of us
i made a joke ten minutes ago probably
that i don't even think it's funny now
but the fact is
i don't think it was funny but my mind i
should have said it but 10 minutes ago i
thought it was funny
but the point is you're at least you're
taking the risk at least you're trying
yeah
for the people who just sit there in the
safe zone and just go everything's safe
here absolutely i i know
what's morally right yeah like we've all
been in that space we do that on true
news all the time and there are plenty
of you wouldn't be a comedian if you did
no but that's the point
like brian the problem for brian and i
is we've run up with people on true news
who take themselves very
very seriously horrible and then they
send us messages afterwards and go well
what's this and you're like
mate you can say whatever you want back
it's absolutely fine it doesn't mean i
wouldn't recommend that much
question though like you know where is
the line i mean it depends on the person
i guess and depends on how well you know
them
but if we don't know them which is the
general thing of what you we all do
around yeah
thank you if someone acts like a [__]
you deserve you're allowed to tell me
but deserve to be talking yeah you know
what i mean yeah i think i think the
only difference is if you
i know
where i know people are making videos on
other people i know
and i've gone to them and gone i don't
think you want to make that video not
because it's
like i'm going to be able to be an
example please no i'm not giving an
example
i don't think you want to be the person
who pushes that person to the edge and i
wouldn't say that if it wasn't very very
serious
and i've gone i've got i've gone number
one you don't want to push somebody too
far
oh and there's a video and it's funny as
long as the video is funny i don't think
it matters the joke just has to be
if the video is funny and the other
person takes it very seriously
it's like you know but if you're going
if you're going really in on somebody
and you know that they're at a bad point
yeah then you've got to take some
responsibility the problem is sometimes
it isn't
actually so there are some people who
we've encountered i think online where
i think they think they're being funny
right and they're not being funny yeah
and i
i guess that like you say it's
subjective so anyone can go into any
space and well that's not really very
funny because they don't have the same
reference points as well every
context changes so quickly absolutely so
let me say
if you've never seen the office you
might genuinely look at true news or any
other stuff and go
the [__] are these guys yeah what do you
guys think of this and fiona's going to
tense up now and probably think i
shouldn't say this
well this is something at some point
either she won't yeah she won't come in
i respect that she's on the payroll
[Music]
max doesn't get 40 grand a year i know
it wasn't tesco but you don't like me to
say the place
[__]
let's see what the black people think
stephen how am i supposed to know who i
am unless i'm represented
i've listened to rizzle cakes yeah we
all shove up waitrose brian brian
relates to the snowmen
right we don't have a weight choice in
manchester what are you doing
to get props for a [__] video so
anyway she works in a poundland and
what's the point
let's point out mark upson part of the
f2 is a lovely bloke don't worry about
that
now go on we were talking about where
the line is in comedy right right and
we're talking about how context changes
all the time yeah
so this is something i got a lot of [__]
earlier in the year oh i see that [__]
again
the rose video is over now it was only
two years
and talking about the the dark side of
if somebody hurts like does something
right
so obviously um it's a touchy subject
and i don't know if you want to keep
this in or not right but obviously
there was some tragic news earlier this
year about caroline flack right now
no one would make any light of that
situation it's a terrible terrible
situation yeah
i have a thing on the youtube channel
where i take the piss out i love ireland
all the time of love island somebody
went in
that was uh that claimed that lewis
capaldi wrote the song someone you loved
her so i made the joke oh that's weird
because somebody uh
somebody claimed that no what was it so
i made the joke that there's a song
written about caroline flack as well uh
bruises because she went through the
domestic
then but but the thing is i i i think it
was
a good joke right but it was funny yeah
yeah
and then obviously a couple of months
later everyone's going to the video
going oh this aged terribly i was like
well of course it's
terrible but i'm not making a joke about
what happened to her i'm making a joke
about
the terrible thing yeah that she
supposedly did
so so based on that and you're not you
know you're not saying it's true because
it's a joke can i just say
what she says a setup and a punchline is
clear what that's it
i've got the exact same situation me and
jj did a sketch
three years ago four years ago and he's
uh i'm an american police officer
he's he's uh he's uh i see where this is
yeah i'd love to see the role play but
i'm way over the top
you get it but then people people are
going
taking the clip out of context and going
this age terribly exactly like you did
i'm like no we're making a point about
what they're like in america that's kind
of a point i don't think a lot of people
get that but like how important is cold
parody though yeah
not only is it called parody but like
the whole reason that the king has a
gesture in the court is to bring out
things that you're not allowed to talk
about in like
you know civilized life so the justice
be supposed to be able to stand there
and say whatever they want i'll see that
in the coroner
and everyone the queen should have a
jester yeah peter k comes out yeah
garlic bread
basically you're supposed to be able to
walk out and that person is supposed to
be able to go
here's a joke that makes light of
something and the whole point of a joke
is there's like a hint of truth at the
very center of it that everyone's going
god that's funny but it's
yeah like it hinges on that because if
the joke's not true in some way then
everyone just sort of goes
well i don't know what it is yeah that's
part of why some jokes work for some
people and some people don't because
some people get what the truth in that
moment is
when you were saying [__] you genuinely
meant that didn't you no but that's the
thing
here's the funny thing right i i
genuinely love that
sweet call for me i love chatting about
just like trivial [__]
right but that's just not what we do
yeah
but that's fine yeah like genuinely i'd
like to know jack
jack whitehall what'd he get a meal deal
right didn't you know i would
i'd love to know what that you say it's
the normality yeah no you and jack
whitehall that was yeah i liked
him i do like him
he's a he's a good comedian i'll tell
you
someone random that intimidated me quite
a lot when i met them someone that you
you're
you're pals with paul catwood logan paul
sean would and
i know that's going to make me seem like
a bit of a simp or whatever no no but
i'll tell you what like
you want to [__] i think i'm
confident enough to like if i call
someone out online
when i see him in person i can carry on
that and like and call him out
that was the first time where i felt
like a bit of a butler when i went to
the fight and i've i've called logan
paul out
numerous times of course then gail
played
and this is the thing yeah so he's
walked past me and we're doing this
whole thing about his dad
and that was the first time where i
completely bottled it and alfie was
there and i went
i'm not going to speak to him and then i
walked away and alfie's like
you have to speak to him
it's the guy in it i mean right now
logan's a bigger star on youtube
yeah i mean how he's dragged floyd
mayweather it will fight with them
this is throw it out yeah this is this
should never have happened yeah can i
just say
any uh any big stars watching i was the
uh draft champion in year five
what did you do you were ten logan
started boxing
in 2018. three years later he's fighting
the greatest fighter of all time you
can't you can't knock him no
this is it and i generally believe he's
one of the main people who has
actually turned around and changed yeah
he's so self-aware now logan paul's
speech on the blm movement was [__]
powerful
he's got the english he's got like the
english personality
[Applause]
that he is the living embodied class now
yeah cancelled is [__]
and what annoys me is i was one i feel
like i was one of the first british
youtubers to actually see
oh you're actually when i made friends
with them say
you're [__] two-faced [__] you're
supposed to be into chaos
he's all right thinking about jack's
situation
you're literally trying to take the piss
out of this guy's dad
by this point logan is a trained fighter
um kill me logan is a big lad like
like what was he six three i did cheeto
in year six
um and he's walking i i get what
like the him and jj thing um they're
very different people actually
like jj's more local he's british type
blood yeah yeah
he more likely have his hood up not
really he plays it down yeah
he walks in the room and he's like i'm
here yeah logan's more like lambo
lamborghini
you know what i mean um my cousin said
to me once that there's people in life
that like who are
maybe famous or on the way up that when
they walk in the room you can tell
there's that and i think when i met him
he was someone where i was like
i can tell there's something about you i
think that's actually how yeah i did a
podcast with you today
that's object you know i think jake
living in his brother's shadow or
whatever the [__] going on there
i think that that's where this [__]
anger comes from
it's like if you can imagine being the
shorter
not as good looking not as charismatic
not as
adored maybe as is logan is destined
smelly
like your you're constantly talked about
is
an inferior yeah into logan paul
it's gone to a point where he's like now
i'm going to be the bad guy i'm going to
embrace it yeah
i'm going to lean into this and i think
it's kind of made him
i mean that that call out video of conor
mcgregor was the most leaned in bad guy
i've ever seen bro they're [__] he
calls his wife within five seconds of
the person video stuff i mean he's got a
team there who's gone yeah go with that
mate yeah i mean i think he was about 30
seconds
like a clever move from jake but i just
found it so cringy i just thought it
could be done so much better
like it would it rashes it because if
that's
and i understand why it's clever him
calling him out but if that's clever
then anyone can do it i mean it raises
his stock tenfold
yeah do you think he purposely made that
video
[__] mate if i do that in front of my
mum's
uh mini cooper who's going saving me
the point that it made as a fight fan
the point that it made me think is
god you're you're actually showing how
this should be done in a way like other
fighters
the reason mcgregor got where he got was
because he knew how to talk [__]
yeah he he's talk this is the thing
floyd mayweather has been finessed into
a fight with logan paul
jake is in the process of trying to
finesse these big names
he's got an ideas to buy it like that
he's got them all on strings immediately
absolutely they're all tripping up
because
they know he this is crazy but him
as a whatever how many fights he's had
will make more money
for with them absolutely than they can
make in the ufc or in the boxing ring
they're fighting a real fight
yeah yeah that's why they've become big
draws immediately
think about how long nate diaz has
fought for years and years it's crazy
and then michael bisping just said like
they've been in contact with him about
jake paul fighting michael
like you're romero as well yeah he's
called him out this thing's been like
i'll do it
where do i start isn't it people are
talking about like mma fans going oh
what'd you make of these youtubers
talking about that but all the mma
fighters are calling out these youtubers
going i'll take the fight
but your murrah has just left the ufc
he's calling out jake paul instantly
i get it to play devil's advocate
does that mean we're missing out on some
of the
great fights of our time because these
people are going cool i can cash in
no no this is the problem
in the ufc and in boxing they're both
not giving the fans what they want to
see yeah yeah so
jake and logan have come in and gone we
can exploit this
and they're dragging these fighters into
fights with them because
the ufc there's so many fights that
should have happened in the last 12
months that haven't happened and it's
not just because of [__] corvette
it's because they're not
getting like conor mcgregor hasn't
fought in 12 months yeah why not you
know what i mean there's
france hasn't gone who should have had a
[__] world title fight hasn't
happened
you've got aj hasn't been only just
fought first time
tyson fury not fought in 12 months all
of it was stopped and he's a fighting
man
we're starved to fight good fights and
logan and jake are staring the ship
going i'll fight any use i'll get the
money together i've got rich mates we'll
all
make it happen like it's actually really
small it's good for the sport
isn't it though whichever sport they
choose to pick on is good for it
is there an element of when when jake
paul calls calls out these people like
is he is his ego so big that he thinks
he has a chance or does he know he'll
get beat up
i think i think he thinks the other
chance really
yeah yeah as long as you're in the ring
with someone you've got to check out a
chance
yeah really really i mean i think he'd
just turn
to the extension the amount of training
he does and the coaches
you've got to think about the people
around him they're all going yeah you'll
do this i guess also
they know if he goes for it they get
paid but the problem is brian there is
there is a point where the money that
you earn from it outstrips the skill
level that you have right so
he's sitting there with a 50 million
dollar check next to his car the skill
that he's going to exhibit for the
amount of money that he's getting is not
proportional
i feel that mcgregor call out was
inspired directly by me whether i think
he's like
who do i go after my brother's got me
with her absolutely yeah
they're constantly competing the only
person who's a bigger star than
mayweather
yeah even though mayweather wouldn't it
doesn't matter he's the biggest star
he's like i've got to drag him
into this yeah and mcgregor has he's
read the message
and i replied what's that mcgregor
so he's [__] up there he's gone past
the first sentence
yeah i'll see that yeah yeah he's bitten
yeah
[__] him it's about like as soon as you
call the wife
that's when you've got a little bit
that's the bit there is i think the
public then go cool you've not called
out conor mcgregor you've actually just
dissed this
white and also true she's actually a
beautiful woman she's
a beautiful woman that's such a bust i'd
move to 50 million
for a fight i mean obviously i'm not
conor mcgregor but i'll take that
for a [__] scrap for
logan have a chance against mayweather
not a chance not a chance in hell no way
like who cares she wins do you know what
it is do you know if this was a real
fight
like i don't know what this i've got to
feel like a street fighter i know i
don't know what's going to happen like
this super exhibition i don't know oh
shank yeah
well it seems like there's zero chance
but my mate who's into boxing reckons
now if you get one punch then it could
be maybe mayweather
is it again are we listening in the wind
here yeah absolutely i mean
like no i genuinely would like this is
the thing
oh god this we like we learned this with
mcgregor not if logan
not mayweather out i wouldn't be shocked
i would i would what 15 0
i'm not saying this is going to happen
before people but
when a [__] 200 pound man it's a
150 pound man well yeah
it could happen you can have the ability
to land on him though well
i mean it's it's unlikely he's going in
like a punch like
it's not like there's
the greatest boxer of all time he is
though
are you saying nay but he's not knocking
logan paul
i'm telling you like he's out of scoring
is not finishing that is a
huge thing for me that's a win i
is it so it took them 10 rounds to get
i'll do that
logan is very fit he's very big and he's
very strong
to bring a man that size down
floyd doesn't knock like small guys out
within six rows really
skill-wise it's different ricky
skill-wise they're floyd floyd fights
guys
skill-wise i'm just saying you're not
not been logging out he's not going to
finish him i'd i'd finish him
i'd go finish him off focus here we go
logan
you're faster your podcasters and all
that mate
and then i'll come on his face all right
this has gotten the right
seriously though
what was our greatest moment of 2020
because it's been difficult
finish the podcast on that yeah that's a
nice ending all right yeah
best best moment of 2020 go on brian my
best moment of 2020
well kind of sharing in it was lauren
speaker
that's nice that was my happiest morning
yeah that's nice
i think 2020 has been a shared year of
um
wins in the sense that we've gotten some
contracts we've really wanted
but also obviously i think a tough year
for everyone
i actually think all of us have probably
received messages from people where
they've been like you know what
it's been the worst year of my life blah
blah blah and i felt really terrible
about it then i was doing true news or
us doing podcasts
that's a good point is uh with so just
to give a shout out a gym shot when jim
sharp
uh came in i was like not really
thinking about like looking after myself
and stuff
and i was like [__] me i should probably
start like you know
trying to try to look like i got the gym
again for 40 grand i would have
there was more than that
thank you very much all seriousness
shark of the gym am i right
thank you jim sharp the first sort of
brand deal i got that sort of um
stopped the worry a little bit you know
because things were getting a bit
absolutely [__] in the waters yeah so
and then i started really getting myself
fit again trying to look after myself
so brian you are looking good by the way
hello hello be right i would
oh he can do that now he can make his
tits dance wow
i can't look at those guys
we love you i lost i lost some
[__] embarrassing happiest moment of
2020 stephen
um i'm just staying with my girlfriend
she's a good girl set the bar high
stephen what's your relationship
i like that thank you so much on the bed
together
it wasn't uh it was they were just just
just a private one you sent just between
us
she makes me happy every day so what's
your relationship like
what like on a daily basis are you two
just sort of joking with each other
or yeah pretty much honestly it's it's a
it's a very good relationship i can't
complain
yeah she makes me happy every day so
here to zoey
here's to elliot hackney off off-camera
yeah
to all the blow jobs elliott am i right
who's off camera as well
to all the [__]
in my mouth just not give
i don't think you can say this but i
think it's been a very mixed year for
you am i right and saying that
yeah it's been a weird year it's been a
weird difference can i be honest
it's been a weird one to observe from
the outside of you because
foreign
the funny thing is actually knowing you
i've i think this is the year probably
obviously you and i don't spend a lot of
time together we do spend football time
together
most people yeah but you are a very nice
person to spend time with
but i think also it's been you you have
had us
by comparisons whether it's probably
quite a hard and bad year where it's
been like there's been a lot of people
being
quite um like harsh on you
like quite difficult thank you and i
also think when you're
then left on your own after that in
lockdown i like respect to you for
coming through it and then making it
into a positive because i think a lot of
people just sort of go
no my narrative is negative and i'm just
going to be well i think my year was
your reflection really
doing this because i was mainly just
doing everything out of fear
because we we even saw that football
like i think you can see week to week
you can see when you're at football
you can see when you're out here and you
can see when you're sad like
you can genuinely i think if you like if
you've got a group of mates that you
play football
it's very true you can see in that week
when someone's having a good week or a
bad week because when they miss
something then they go
[__] their heads out of it yeah yeah
exactly or if you miss something and
you're having a bad week you'd be like
[__] out like a really
you can see the weeks when you were
first what's your number selling them
aren't they
right genuinely that's a great question
i was just not a kick off but
it was a weird one to watch because i
think a lot of people are like [__] like
what's going on with you
a little bit like i maybe the exact same
exactly right
but yeah for me i think the whole year
was um
big just learning experience really
figuring out
who i am because it because it was very
easy good mug it's very easy with
youtube as we were saying earlier with
people like jeremy lynch when you're
doing really well
just be like just you just be like
not mine i'll just carry on doing what
i've always done and
that will be it and i'll just accept and
this is what i've done it forever
but for this year i was like i need to
take a step out and really just be like
what do i actually want to do because
it's so easy to get caught up
in this whole thing because there's
money am i doing the
boys especially like especially with the
bake off and
the the art challenge you did with
laurence it shows you off as more of a
personality
not like uh not like i still think
that's why yeah
it's very good for you i stopped
uploading on the main not necessarily
because i've
run out of ideas i had so many ideas but
because i was like
i'm clearly so much happier on there
yeah
and almost in a weird way doing that was
great but it's most highlighted
and now you're happy as well who would
have been there
i think it's a good time to bring out
very good
[Laughter]
my happiest moment is not the spotify
thing at all like
my happiest moment is uh finding out
liam payne's favorite meal dude that's
it yeah i can't believe it's a tuna
sweet corn mental
but my happiest moment is uh being with
being employed by my
lifelong club west ham united to become
an american
forever
you've been through and i think most of
us have observed it like you've been
through
been for the question yeah yeah yeah for
sure like
a few years ago you were quite sardonic
quite sort of uh cynical
quite sort of he's happier generally
isn't he you do seem a lot happier just
a bit of a shame really i prefer when
he's miserable
i can i can turn it on for you there
must also be
an element of you which does go like
what it's very difficult to change
fundamentally in that way
in such a short space of time because
you and you and i both notice it we've
obviously watched a lot of your videos
we listened to your podcasts
we've noticed a difference in your
demeanor and even the way that you treat
things the way you treat subjects all
that kind of stuff
like has that been a conscious change
for you i think it was weird because
people that knew me well was always
fascinated back in the day how i'd be
able to slag people off yeah when they
knew me and
like people would meet me and go you
don't actually give a [__] i've never
really given a [__] about things the
ultimate goal has been to have a laugh
right and i became this guy that was
would slag people off
though to your videos yeah you wouldn't
accept that yeah of course yeah
i don't know how i fell into that
category i think
the first time i ever slag something off
i think it did well so i just kept doing
it
yeah and then ultimately i'm i'm to my
core i think i'm a nice person but you
can't do comedy and be like
exactly so you have to either pick one
or the other exactly there's comments
the comedy's inherently negative isn't
it
i grew up with my dad he's one of the
funniest people i i know and
met him at me and he would he would
watch the
tv and make comments about it and they'd
always be friends
they'd always be negative but they'd
always be funny because it's funnier to
be
negative about things that's correct
yeah and then i met fiona and she was
like
she drilled it into me like you can't
always be negative about everything
it'll weigh you down
so i actively tried her
[Music]
to be fair that must actually be quite
difficult to be in a relationship with
someone who's always going oh here's the
he's the negative side of that or he's
the funniest yeah he's one of the most
positive cheerful people you'll ever
meet
so it was like her fault he's not
funnier yeah
there are still elements of your
personality which are still quite sort
of um
yeah because even the other night you
post a photo of yourself with her and
you were like but my fantasy football
team is this
i love that but the focus is really the
photo of you with her
but then my fantasy football team is
pretty [__]
that was a that was a conscious decision
to make it a bit more
negative i mean because because i am a
positive person
but how does the jack make persona
survive if i'm not sagging things off so
really to be fair
it's a really in many in many ways it's
like quite a brave decision to make
because i also think a lot of channels
people come to you for the the vibe the
persona all these things yeah
and for a lot of people it's very
difficult you you know this as well to
like change your persona
yeah and go i'm going to do this now and
you're going to come with me yeah
like you know that right i can't
continue to call people out
unless i can make it funny so i have dms
all the time going this person's done
this this person's done that if i can't
make it funny
like a lot of people say the biggest
problems on youtube the biggest issues
i don't touch on them well there you go
that summarizes it because i can't make
it funny yeah if somebody does something
small
the advent calendar from zoey
but the reason why it did well for me is
because i genuinely find it funny
if somebody goes out tomorrow and
[__] kills someone i'm not going to
go and put them in rank bank
it's a bigger issue isn't it so as long
as i can continue to depend on how they
kill them
there's a video that went viral on
twitter of her she made
she like um glued a fidget spinner to it
she puts it in her [__] and she
flicks the fidget spinner right and uh
thank you not the fidget spinner great
video
what is this how much yeah he was that
it was that
same one that was in the video wow that
must be worth a lot of money yeah
and that was the highlight of this man
you got bed club hi later this year
the highlight of this year are you
alright man
stephen really is a like yeah if
i love my girlfriend because she'll
watch this and this is the redeeming
factor i get from it
stephen uh if you're watching zoey
uh he loves you you're beautiful um
you're doing far too well to be
with me brian i guess we'll just shout
out
how can i just say how nice it is though
to be back on the tuesday
this week it was gonna happen the
invites went out quite late we were both
very busy with other stuff
sort of went the other way raising a
child
he's been he's he's editing you'll see
steven tries
yeah a little bit more important i think
not only that
i've definitely raised you as i'm how
many subscribers has he got yeah i mean
yeah no not over a million i think brian
yeah
she's she's all done beautiful you look
beautiful off why'd you make yourself up
like that and then i said
why's he said love yeah oh sexy how do
we keep the butt plug in
wow wow if anything i hope she'll get up
i've got i've got i've got a book plug
on mr potato head
my mate pulled it off the engineers came
around the other day yeah
the electricians they're [__] staring
at mr
potato head with a bug plug on the side
what the [__]
i'm going mate i've lost them stop
looking at them okay
you're the history of the electrics not
the blood block
forget that you're not going to connect
the bubble to the [__] mister's head
i did that first simon video i did that
to make tobe just laugh
so merry christmas the true johnny
podcast
christmas special here's to you big star
one two three i hope you enjoyed it
don't forget to subscribe
uh hit the like button we'll see you
next christmas
maybe not after that i'll be
oh man